why you know we could try oh g or g3
yeah g4 or g3 i don't know which one is
maybe
one of these moves i mean yeah just
hoping that there might be a trade and
that later the white king can sneak in
yeah um i get a passport you know it's
an ending but okay this is still a draw
even if uh this is
played this is still a draw because i
don't think white's king can get much
further into the position he hasn't even
gone for this the underpony actually
but uh also even if you push with this
pawn i think black can just wait i think
this this square is covered and it's
about to be a draw let's go back to the
players it's a move 42 david oh okay one
it's moving forward
it's going to be forward
did you get it
we're 41.
david owell to get his perfect score on
uh the magnus network prediction
challenge it's a draw in game three
between jan and pognation minus carlsen
and uh it's a quick draw let's hear if
they talk again today
silence from the playing menu today
no discussion no discussion today jana
pomnyacci is
leaving they have only played for
two and a half hours right
three hours and 42 minutes
no